sister live star Cody and Mary Brown
officially call it quits and Mary calls
out the media for spreading what she
calls misinformation about their split
it doesn't surprise me at all the former
couple released a joint statement on
Tuesday updating fans on the status of
their marriage writing quote in light of
a recent unapproved press release we
feel compelled to share our own truth in
our own way and in our own timing before
adding that after a decade of working on
their relationship they've made the
decision to permanently end things the
exes note that they are committed to
kindness and respect toward each other
and all members of their family we're
trying to be honest about how we feel
Mary captioned the post on Instagram
writing in part quote today I reclaim my
power he's like like we're not married
we're not acting as married and I said
to him then if that's where we are
don't you think that we should address
that publicly and he said no I don't
want to address it
I don't want to address it I don't want
that to be out there publicly and
despite saying all that on the recent
Sister Wives one-on-one special Mary
says that wasn't a confirmation of their
split in the months since the taping of
those interviews Cody and I have had
many open and honest discussions that
have led to our announcement today Mary
adds that there is so much more to be
told and assured fans she will
eventually explain everything but for
now Mary says she has peace holds no
animosity towards Cody and asks that
fans refrain from congratulating her on
the end of her marriage quote I value
the relationship I had and look forward
to stepping into 2023 and my future with
Grace kindness and power it's really
hard to look in the mirror sometimes and
be like huh what is it that I need to
change and improve on so I that I can
move forward you know you just work
through it and then you get to a point
that's good Mary and Cody hide the knot
in 1990 making her Cody's first wife the
two struggled to conceive but eventually
welcomed their child Leon Brown in 1995.
I am still here because I'm still trying
six years later I'm still here 10 years
15 20 years later I'm still here
it's what I want ironically Mary's
trying to support me and I don't want to
be in a relationship with her anymore
Mary and Cody illegally divorced in 2014
so that Cody could legally marry his
fourth wife Robin and adopt her kids
from a previous relationship as for Mary
she remained spiritually married to Cody
he has chosen not to love me and not to
want a relationship with me and so far
is to consider himself not married to me
of course Cody and his third wife
Christine split in 2021 he's also
separated from his second wife Janelle
Cody's only remaining marriage is to his
fourth wife Robin so what's next for
Mary last month she posted this pic to
Instagram seemingly teasing that she's
ready to tell her side of the story
foreign